hi there steve here on my 90 day korean
challenge
you know i set myself the goal of uh
getting up to 50 000 known words
uh the way i
acquire known words is actually there
are several ways but one way is to read
new lessons that contain words that i
haven't seen before
and therefore they're new to me in link
in the system
and as i read through it some of them i
save
because i need to i don't know what they
mean so i look them up and i
what we call create links they become
part of my database some of them i don't
need to look up and they simply become
known words so plowing through new
material adds to my known words total
however i also find now that i need to
review some of the material i went
through earlier and i want to sit down
with hannah and go through and get some
explanations because i'm now at a stage
where i want more explanations
when we start in a language i find
explanations are a little bit
overwhelming i kind of want to explore
the language myself see what i can find
out make some wrong assumptions about
what things mean but i don't mind i kind
of move along but now i want to start to
get a better sense so if i go back to
lessons where there are no blue
new words
then
i won't be able to reach my target so
there's this dilemma do i spend my time
on on old lessons to review and get a
better handle on them or do i keep
plowing through new material new
material is also more interesting so i
want to show you how i use the
vocabulary section to increase my
uh known word total and to you know get
credit for words that i now have
actually known from the links that i
created i'm doing this on the beta i
have the beta on my iphone and my ipad
some of you who have
the app
you have the old app if you want to use
the new beta app
then you can
comment on the former contact customer
support and we're happy to put more
people on the beta there are still
things that we're working out on the
beta things that need to be improved
features that need to be uh you know
brought in but i enjoy it i think it's
great using the beta that's my favorite
way of using link right now so please
let us know if you would like to get on
the beta and here is a brief
demonstration of me using the vocabulary
section bye for now
all right now there was quite a bit of
interest in how i used the system so i
don't know how well this is going to
work maybe we want to maybe reduce it a
little bit there i think that's good
enough so
one of the things that i want to do now
is because i've saved a bunch of phrases
and of course i save a phrase simply by
doing this
and then dragging that over
and that creates a phrase
very often the google translate
uh translation isn't correct
but what it does it gives me these
darkened phrases and i'm going to sit
down with hannah and she's going to
explain them to me one of the things i
find is that if you get a lot of
explanation at an early stage in the
language is kind of meaningless but now
i've had enough experience with korean
that i want to get a little more
explanation of some of these things that
i think i know what they mean or how
they work but i want a little more
explanation so that's one thing i want
to show you the other thing i wanted to
show you was and i'm going to get out of
this lesson so i quit
and here are all of my uh the lessons in
this one podcast from
uh
this
kim
kim jong-bay and if i go and look at my
different courses of course i've got a
variety of courses kim jong-bay and kbs
drama and a whole bunch of other stuff
but i won't go into how our
lesson feed works because i'll show that
some other time but what i wanted to
show you here is i have the option of
going into my vocabulary
all right because oh one of the things i
wanted to show you is i have about 39
000
known words
i and so i say i'd like to you know get
it up to forty thousand but
if i do that then i don't have a chance
to review the old lessons
to create new known words i have to go
into lessons that have a lot of these
blue unknown words but the other thing i
can do is to go into the links that i
have already saved and there's thirty
seven thousand nine hundreds of of these
and promote some of them move some of
them to known because in fact i know
some of them so i can search here
and i can decide to search by importance
because probably the higher frequency
words are the ones that i already know
but haven't moved to known so i go apply
and then it brings up these four dot
words four ball words these are words
that are high frequency some of them
i've already moved to known
but some of them i haven't so i know hey
for c
so i can edit this list and i can go
okay this guy and you know
this is i know this now
and go for the ones that i already know
uh you know what i did wrong i'm gonna
stop this i'm gonna go done
and i'm gonna to go
back to
search again and i'm going to change my
search criteria and i'm going to say i
only want to see the ones that i'm not
so familiar with because i include the
ones i included the ones that i was very
familiar with so i'll try and apply this
list again and this time
we have
more words that i can upgrade
so here i'm going to edit
all right so i know hey
i know
uh
okay these are words that that onan
uh onan is coming i'll leave that i'm
not so familiar with that uh something
mulgo besides so i want to move these
to gnome so i go mark none
and now i have
moved these so what that does and of
course
you'll see the number here of my links
has been reduced i could show you
elsewhere that the number of my known
words has increased so i'm now going to
go through and maybe grab a few hundred
of these
links that i have convert them to known
so that i can push my known words total
over 40 000 because i kind of motivated
to
maintain or to achieve my goals so
that's enough for today and
if you're interested occasionally i can
show you how i use the system okay then
bye for now